"Будинок-вбивця" - так без перебільшення
називають гуртожиток на Лісовому масиві в Києві його мешканці.
Будівлю почали зводити в 70-их роках як тимчасове житло для чоловіків.
Зараз тут мешкають цілими сім'ями.
При будівництві тут припустились серйозного порушення -
каналізаційні стоки "зашили" прямо в стіни.
Тож через відсутність вентиляції  це місце
стало раєм для грибків і пеклом для людей.
Ось тут грибок все порушив. Все роз'їв.
Люди намагались робити ремонт. Але сюди жодний сантехнік не йде.
Ось плита їде. Aspergillus niger - це назва грибка,
який роз'їдає легені і бронхи
і викликає людей в рак.
Рівень концентрації токсинів в повітрі будинку перевищує норму в 13 разів.
Та навіть без спеціальних приборів у будинку відчувається сире, задушливе повітря.
Дихати тут нестерпно важко.
До 80 відсотків житлових будинків в Україні застарілі
і 8% з них непридатні для життя,
підрахували в Міністерстві розвитку громад і територій України.
Це переважно радянські п’ятиповерхові цегляні
і панельні будинки, так звані "хрущовки".
Їх почали масово будувати ще наприкінці 1950-их років
за правління секретаря компартії Микити Хрущова. Звідси і назва.
Про комплексну ревіталізацію успадкованого радянського житла
українська влада заговорила в 2006 році,
коли ухвалила відповідний закон  -
"Про комплексну реконструкцію кварталів застарілого житлового фонду".
А вже через кілька років, в Києві, за часів Олександра Попова,
анонсували пілотний проект зі знесення "хрущовок" на Нивках.
Тоді влада виділила забудовнику землю для стартового будинку,
куди в подальшому мали переселити мешканців знесених "хрущовок".
Утім, забудовник вирішив не продовжувати проект ще на етапі будівництва,
бо не побачив в ньому комерційної вигоди.
Відтоді процес ревіталізації "хрущовок" у столиці практично не зрушив з мертвої точки.
Андрій Рижиков з девелоперської компанії, яка саме шукає нові ділянки
для житлової та комерційної забудови, знає чому.
За його словами, ухвалений майже 15 років тому закон
аж ніяк не сприяє ревіталізації "хрущовок".
Адже згідно з ним, для ремонту чи знесення будинку
необхідна стовідсоткова згода його мешканців.
Одна відмова - і весь проект заблокований.
З промзоною простіше: ти маєш одного попереднього власника
і ти маєш  десятки гектарів вільної для забудови території.
А коли таких власників 200 -300 сімей
і в кожного своя проблема особиста, це важко.
Крім того, визнання застарілими тільки п’ятиповерхових будинків
заважає проводити комплексну реконструкцію мікрорайонів,
які включають і старі й аварійні дев'ятиповерхові будинки.
Слід також змінити схему відшкодування квартирних площ для мешканців застарілого житла.
Не потрібно брати всіх, хто прописаний в цій квартирі.
Тобто метри міняємо на метри і з розширенням.
Це дуже позитивно.
Але якщо місто у цьому не буде приймати участь, то навіщо цим займатись?
Якщо береш квартал, то там є якесь інженерне навантаження.
І коли ти збільшуєш щільність,
з 5-7 поверхів будуєш 12-14 поверхів
і треба більше ресурсів інженерних
і  дуже хотілося б, щоб це забезпечувало місто.
Саме місто на рівні місцевої влади проблему реконструкції "хрущовок" усвідомлює.
У новому Генплані Києва окреслили межі житлових масивів,
які є потенційно цікавими для ревіталізації.
Йдеться про цілі квартали "хрущовок",
а це 7 млн квадратних метрів житлової площі.
Мілютенка, ось тут, так зване "соцмістечко",
всі території, які зайняті біля Ленінградської площі.
На Правому березі це у нас і Солом'янка,
тут багато 5-поверхової забудови,
на вулиці Маршала Гречка
є 5-ти поверхова забудова.
Водночас в "Інституті Генерального плану міста Києва"
сумніваються в можливості масштабного запуску процесу,
опоки не буде схвалено новий профільний закон
та допоки ще не повністю вичерпаний ресурс вільних земель під будівництво.
Сергій Броневицький, керівник Інститут, пояснює:
наразі забудовники ще продовжують освоювати промислові території.
Однак через 3-5 років і такої землі не буде.
Реновація і відселення - це більш дорогий метод будівництва,
ніж просто побудувати на вільній ділянці. Ми це розуміємо.
Інвестору треба віддати більше ніж 40% житла
тим мешканцям, які вже живуть на цій території,
а це здорожчання на 40% будівництва.
Тому інвестори на це поки не йдуть.
Крім того, немає, на нашу думку, законодавчої бази.
Вимоги законодавців щодо згоди всіх 100% - це утопія.
Такого ніколи не буде. І це необхідно міняти.
Проблема реконструкції соціального тимчасового житла
свого часу поставала, зокрема, і в таких європейських країнах,
як Німеччина, Латвія, Чехія та Польща.
От-тільки там ревіталізація розпочалася ще тридцять років тому
і приємно вражає, розповідає аналітик Павло Федорів.
Найчастіше житло не зносили, а ремонтували.
Робили енергоефективним, прибудовували лІфти, зводили додаткові поверхи.
Це дозволяло інвестору заробляти  на таких проектах гроші,
а мешканцям отримати якісне помешкання.
Втім, Україна такий досвід навряд чи використає.
Адже в Європі мешканці житла співфінансували ремонти.
Влада ж брала на себе ті об'єкти, які їй і належали.
Україна в цьому плані доволі унікальна, оскільки
не так багато країн вдавалось до такої масової безкоштовної приватизації,
коли, з одного боку, помешкання і  будинки були віддані в приватну власність,
з іншого боку,  капітальний ремонт на них, утримання,
не фінансувалось за рахунок цих же мешканців.
Податок на нерухомість майже не існує,
орендної плати за землю немає.
Власність в Україні дуже дешева,
але з іншого боку ця власність не гарантує вам якісних житлових умов.
В країнах, де проводились ремонти чи реконструкції,
власник мав кошти на це.
Утім, не все так безнадійно. Ревіталізація за європейською схемою,
але на український манер, наприклад, відбулась в Києві за адресою Гарматна, 20.
Зусиллями київського комунального підприємства "Спецжитлофонд"
тут звели стартовий будинок, в який переселили лише тих мешканців старого гуртожитку-"сталінки",
які могли доплатити за додаткові квадратні метри.
Хто грошей не мав -  мусив добровільно-примусово переселятись в інші гуртожитки.
Ми задоволені, але ми дуже довго боролись. 10 років,
щоб з цього будинку в цей перейти. Нас хотіли виселити.
І не зрозуміло, чи ми б вернулись. А так все нормально.
Ми відселились, там два роки жили, а потім переїхали.
10% платили пенсіонери й матері-одиначки,
30% -  які стояли 20 років на черзі,
і 40% - всі інші.
В компанії "Спецжитлофонд" на запит DW відповіли,
що ревіталізація цього гуртожитку виявилась "достатньо успішною"
з "рентабельністю проекту 21%".
До речі, саме це комунальне підприємство
нині будує нове помешкання і для жителів "будинку-вбивці".
Швидке переселення людям персонально обіцяв мер Віталій Кличко
і виконання його обіцянки тут з нетерпінням чекають з 2016 року.
Аби орієнтовно у жовтні переїхати могли всі і без доплат,
"Спецжитлофонд" навіть підняв з архівів старі будівельні плани.
Для жителів гуртожитку квартири будують за старими будівельними нормами -
з маленькими кухнями та кімнатами.
Двохкімнатні 52-55 кв. метрів.
Це стандартна радянська квартира 90-х років.
В планах мерії разом з "будинком-вбивцею" знести
ще 7 аварійних "хрущовок" на Лісовому масиві.
А на їхньому місці збудувати комерційно вигідні багатоповерхівки.
Тож, можливо, цей успішний досвід стане взірцем для ревіталізації "хрущовок"
і в інших районах Києва.  А може, й в інших містах України.